Hello everybody!
Oh wait, I think Discord cut you out.
Oh shoot!
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yeah!
Hello!
Do you want to do my intro?
Yeah, let's do it.
Okay, do you know my intro?
Boy?
Uh huh?
Moe!
Boe!
Yeah!
Go ahead!
Hello!
Everybody say hello to Phoebe!
That's, that's me!
That's you!
The bee of the Phoebe variety, that's me!
We're both members of Densetsu.exe.
Everybody, go listen to Densetsu MVPs right now.
Actually, after this, after this.
Forever, lupin.
When we say MVP forever, we mean listen to it on repeat
forever.
Forever.
Yeah!
Do you want to do your intro?
Sure.
I love yours.
It's just so cute.
You too.
Oh, wait.
What if we did my call and response, but you can do the
response part.
Oh, okay, okay.
That'd be kind of cute, okay.
Okay.
The best times have no fee.
Who's the bee causing all the buzz?
Phoebe!
This is a dream come true.
Ohachi!
I am Phoebe, your 2.5D, blooming flower, idol singer,
songwriter, and voice actor from densetsu.exe and I love
minto!
So much!
I love Phoebe hive and I love Aibus and I am an Aibu as
well.
Yeah!
Ohachi!
Oh, Hachi.
Thanks for having me.
I said fee.
I didn't say there was no- The best times have no feet?
I'm not sound- No.
The best times do have feet.
Your feet.
The best times?
Probably include feet.
Probably.
Most like.
How are you going to get up and grooving and moving, you
guys?
Exactly.
How are you going to jam and jive without- I mean, you can
still wiggle.
You can, uh, you can shrimp around even if you got your
feet.
you know we still need to see Phoebe's famous shrimping move
on the shrimp actually it doesn't involve feet you're so
right it just involves me in the fetal position on the
ground yeah yeah so you don't need feet but I mean fun times
do have feet usually quite often yeah we guys we're gonna
chit chat a little bit we're gonna hang out and just you
know be gals until we get into the cookies of it all so um
yes but i do want to say before anything i want to say dev
sisters thank you so much for sponsoring my one stream but
we'll get into the we'll get into the uh the business later
i am very excited for some cookie business though i i cookie
run kingdom was my life for so long i miss i love it i'm so
excited to y'all with you about it and to explore some of
the new stuff that's gonna, that has been going on recently
in the world of Cookie Run.
Cookie Run.
You, you know, I was thinking, I was like, oh my gosh,
Phoebe is so perfect for this, not just because of that, but
also because you also, you actually bake.
I do.
I love baking a lot and my favorite thing to make for
people.
I guess baking is one of my love languages, but my favorite
thing to make for friends And I want to make for you one day
is my chocolate chip cookies that have taken many years of
adjustment to make just right.
Is it like copyrighted?
Um, no, no, but, but my, uh, patented, patented work.
Perhaps it's true.
Well, my, my mom's like, you can't just go spreading your
secret recipe everywhere like that.
And here I am like pinning it in my announcements channel on
my Discord.
I'm like, everyone go make these cookies.
secrets and I'm like why should I gatekeep joy that's so
true oh you're just too nice Phoebe you're too nice you do
it for the love of the game I do but should I not well I
feel like if only you're going to like I don't know like
write a book a recipe book or something I was thinking one
day long after the idle days of of having a bakery
restaurant one day Oh my gosh!
I want to come!
I want to come and eat here!
Free food for you whenever you come.
Free food for Minto.
That's bad business.
I mean...
Does that mean you're going to be there every day?
I might.
Worth.
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner, baby.
Oh, baby!
You're still living in my house at that point.
Also try happy birthday!
Sorry, I missed it.
Oh my gosh, happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, someone said play Dokopon Kingdom at some point.
Have you heard of Dokopon Kingdom?
It is a friendship destroyer.
I just played one.
It is the friend.
You know, people say that like, Mario Party is a friendship
destroyer, but Dokopon Kingdom creates real enemies.
It really does.
Like, could we dance it to Dokopon?
That would be insane.
Wait, what if we did a special series?
I don't know if it'd be over like a week or a few weeks or
like a whole month where we do all of the friendship
challenge games and we see how powerful we are, how strong
our friendship is.
So we start at like easy level, which is like golf with
friends or something.
We're speedrunning our villain arc.
We are.
Monopoly, Uno, Mario Party.
What else is there?
Among us?
Maybe.
Does Amongas destroy friendships, does it?
I think it makes you question your friendship because you're
like, how did I know?
I never knew this person could be so deceitful.
I don't think I knew them from the beginning.
See, that's the pre-gaming for it.
That's the pre-gaming before golf with friends.
We played golf with friends.
That was fun though.
We was fine.
We were fine.
That was off-stream.
We were just playing games together.
Also, Phil, happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
So many birthdays.
Oh, Pico Park.
Oh, my God.
Pico Party.
Pico Park?
Pico Park.
Pico Park can be a Pico Party, it can.
Yeah.
It ain't Pico Park without a Pico Party.
Without a Pico Party or the Pizza Party.
The Pizza Party for the Pico Party for the Pico Park.
Oh, that sounds good.
Pizza.
I know.
Go-to Toppings, Mint.
Go-to Toppings?
Yes.
Okay.
I got this.
Spinach.
Whoa.
Sometimes feta cheese.
Green.
Green pepper.
Pineapple.
Garlic.
That's my go-to pizza.
Okay.
All that sounded real good to me except for the pepper
because I'm a baby that is like.
Oh, I mean, I'll eat my peppers if I have to.
If I have.
Well, green pepper is not like spicy or anything.
You just don't like red pepper or green pepper.
It's a little bitter for me.
Just a little bit.
But you know what?
But I'm growing up.
A lot of the foods that I've like started to acquire tastes
for as an adult, I acquire because I'm trying to like, I'm
trying to save face in front of people.
I don't care if you all hate my pizza.
That means I get to eat all of it.
So I don't care if you hate my pizza.
True.
That's true.
You don't have to share that.
to share.
Phoebe's growing up.
You're growing, you're all big now.
I'm growing up.
It's like, I'll always end up in a situation where I'm with,
like, a friend or a few friends, and then they'll be like,
oh, let's, each of us choose, like, a topping for pizza.
Or each, I'll order sushi, and then you can order a sushi,
and we'll share.
And I'll order, like, my basic stuff.
And they'll be like, okay, um, for example, I only learned
that I love mushrooms because I did a thing.
with someone where i chose half the toppings and they chose
half and then they put mushrooms on it and i was too ashamed
to tell them i was scared of eating mushrooms don't be
afraid so i let them do it oh but then i ended up loving it
man i ended up liking it i was just afraid to try it we were
anti-mushroom together no we can be anti uh do you like
olives no okay we can be anti-olive actually thinking of
this just earlier because I was watching a video of someone
that went on like a fancy it was like a it was like a super
fancy train that was in Japan and they were like and this is
the food that we were served and I was like you know every
time I watch those kinds of things where it's like this is
the fancy menu I'm like I think I I think I don't I think
I'm glad that I'm not a fancy rich person because... Give me
my mac and cheese and chicken nuggets.
Yes!
And my fries.
I just...
Like, the menus are always so...
I'm like, oh, that's what you guys are eating!
And they're small.
They're the tiniest portions ever.
I'm like, really?
Yeah!
Is this enough for you?
It's just... I just... Maybe, like...
Maybe if it's like a fancy meat, I'll be excited about it.
But everything I...
else, I'm like, oh, our arm waiter, mac and cheese, Mac and
cheese, Can I get a grown-up size of this kids menu mac and
cheese, please?
I don't know.
tiny portions, but many courses.
But at the same time, I get full so fast.
Do you?
I do like that, you know, if they're tiny portions of lots
of things and I get to try lots of stuff.
That's true.
And that sounds fun.
I have like...
Sometimes if you have too much of one thing.
You know.
Unless I really like it.
Then I'm like, more, please.
What's something that you could eat a ton of?
Mac and cheese.
Same, same.
We should just have a mac and cheese party sometime.
You brought it up and it's all I could think of right now.
Like five different mac and cheeses.
Spaghetti.
You and me and Ricky.
Yeah!
Oh, spaghetti.
Spaghetti.
Any kind of noodle, I think I'm good with.
with any pasta.
The pastas that they toss around in giant cheese wheels look
so good.
Aye, aye, yes!
Yeah, uh, yes!
Wait, that was you.
When you got the cheese bowl.
Oh, you're right!
You are so right!
Wait, you know, there was that one time when we went out to
a business dinner, but we decided that we both could
probably just share one on.
and then there was no debate about which one we wanted to
get because we both wanted like the lemon pasta option i
think we have a very similar taste i think so i think so
other than the mushrooms that that would do it that would do
it when i go to japan and they're like and i'm like uh i
like omurais that's my favorite japanese food And they're
like, Kawaii.
And I'm like, what do you mean, Kawaii?
It's just delicious.
It's just yummy.
Phoebe, I get it because I go to sushi restaurants and I
get, I get tamago.
I get the egg sushi.
I'm like, it's so good.
It's like nice and sweet too.
Yeah, it's like got a little bit of sweetness.
And then they like have children's plates.
That's like shrimp and tamagoi.
or to the...
Yeah, it comes with a little ebby fry or something.
And I'm like...
This is made for me!
And when it comes to sushi too, I just get a lot...
I like getting a lot of salmon.
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, when we go...
When we go, I'm gonna take you to sushi dough because they
have a salmon basil like with mozzarella cheese on top.
And it is...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know what you're talking about.
Have you added it?
No.
Yeah, because there was one trip where I went to Sushido
like four times.
But it's like, they don't have like...
If you go to like Kura in the state, I love Kura, but
also...
They don't have the strange things.
You would think that an American version of it would have
like...
The cheese, sushi and stuff.
Right, right, right.
No.
Japan.
Yeah, Japan has some wacky things.
It's so good though.
They had one with like a prosciutto and cheese or something.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, those are so good.
Yeah, guys, it's my suggestion.
If you go to sushi dough, the salmon basil is so...
It's actually, like, afterlife changing.
It's so stinking good.
Afterlife changing is cute.
It's so yummy.
Yes, I recommend.
What?
You might just ascend to heaven if you have too much of it.
I'd be careful.
You're right.
I do go sometimes with some friends And they'll literally
get like five plates of it Oh I thought you meant go to
heaven Oh my gosh They're in heaven when they're eating five
plates of salmon basil sushi I think that we should go and
eat five plates of salmon basil sushi I think we could do it
easy Yeah yeah Easily we might have to up it to like 10 Oh
wait what's your max plate number for like A sushi, like a
kaiten sushi like that.
I've never counted.
But you know what?
I try my best to get to the 15 at Kura so I can get a prize.
However, it's not...
I've never been without help before.
Okay, okay.
Because my max, I think, is like, seven.
But I usually go, like, five or six plates.
Yeah, I think seven's about the same.
Six or seven is about...
No.
Don't make that face.
I'm not gonna do it.
Six or...
But in all seriousness...
For your sake, I won't do it.
I will combat the brain worms.
I will combat them.
But yes, in all seriousness, six or seven plates is probably
my typical max.
But then...
But then I want those prizes.
But that's when I go with groups, you know.
Yeah, but I don't actually go to Kura in the States very
much.
I usually go to Sushiro.
I don't think they do prizes.
At Sushiro?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't think so.
No.
But they sometimes have the fun touch screens.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
They do.
With games sometimes.
I don't know if they're games, but little challenges and
stuff.
They cheat you.
I did it.
They do.
I did it once and it was just like, oh, you're going to get
the prize.
And then I don't even know what the prize is because I've
never won.
I just believe there are no prizes.
Oh.
At least it's cheating you.
Yeah, at least with Kura, you get like the little gotcha
porn, right?
Right.
Damn, I've got enough gotcha in my life already as it is.
I don't need my sushi restaurant to also get my hopes up
like that.
Yeah, yeah.
But...
Mmm.
The prizes are cute sometimes.
They really are.
We are going to gotcha today.
Yes, we are.
yes the cool thing though about cookie run is that they're
so generous like i mean i guess you haven't played as much
of it as i have but i was able to be pretty like free to
play for a long time i just like to get the monthly passes
because they come with cute items oh yeah yeah if i like a
game like you know i like i will support it with like a
monthly something or other you know like yeah a monthly
something yeah yeah but not yeah we got we We got some
self-control though.
We're doing our best.
We're hanging in.
Unless it's like a character that I'm like, I must have.
I...
Right.
I have gone a little crazy before.
But I can probably count on the number of one hand how many
times I've gone crazy.
Phoebe.
How many fingers you got on that one hand?
I was born with six Yeah, I The amount of times I've Gone in
really hard for a character It's been that And that many
times Honestly for me But sometimes I want to be strong I
guess I guess Hmm Hmm Sometimes I want to do good in people
That has honestly, like, been a little bit more of a
motivator for me than even collecting my favorite
characters.
I feel like the characters I end up liking, I'm lucky.
In some games, they end up being, like, the free character
or something like that.
And I'm very lucky.
But then, I want to get strong.
I'm tired of being trampled underfoot in PvP.
No, waifu over meta.
No, waifu over meta, Phoebe!
You know what that reminds me of is when...
When I was little, playing Fire Emblem Awakening on the 3DS,
I would like, it was like the first Fire Emblem that
introduced a shipping mechanic and like children mechanic
and stuff.
And I shipped the characters based on how, how like their
chemistry and how cute I thought they were together.
But then all my friends were kind of like, no, I shipped
them for the stats.
Because if you ship these two characters together, they have
a higher stats.
And I was like, no!
No!
Love over Love over Nana.
Love over Nana.
It's like breeding Pokemon.
You know, when you breed them for the best stats and stuff.
Breeding your soldiers for stats.
It sounds so bad.
No.
But people go crazy over that kind of stuff.
They're just like, oh yeah, my Pikachu has this attack and
my other Pikachu has this together they will create the
ultimate weapon I mean good for them but but you got
different priorities different different strokes for
different folks so true yeah so true I'm not sweaty enough
oh yeah you're not sweaty enough yeah well unfortunate oh
you're not yeah you're not sweaty enough so yeah i'm i'll
get i'm i'm actually i get nervous with like sponsored
streams so i'll get a little sweaty later oh oh i see i see
i see i see yeah yeah anyway what are you excited what do
you i'm excited to see what cookies you end up you end up
liking yeah i was going through some of And honestly, I was
like, I was like, oh my gosh, this character, this cookie is
so cute.
And then I was like, wait, this is like their alt outfits.
Like the outfits that they have are so stinking cute.
Oh my gosh, they have such good outfits too.
Yeah.
Which is like the end of me.
Because I'm like, oh, okay, I'm saving up my gems for these
cute cookies.
And I love them so much.
Now I can dress them up.
And the outfits are, the outfit designs are actually peak.
But that's a different currency than the regular.
currency, oh.
You gotta, you gotta, uh, you gotta strategize.
There's lots of ways to earn.
There really is.
However, there's also lots of cute outfits.
So you gotta, you gotta figure out who your priorities,
where your priorities lie.
Can I guess later who your favorite cookie?
Oh wait, there's like so many.
There's like over a hundred.
There's so many now.
If it was like, if this was like a year or two ago, then you
maybe you would have been able to, but there's, there's so
many.
But that means there's like a cookie for everyone out there.
Like how there's a Pokemon for...
I like to think...
Going back to Pokemon a little bit, I like to think that
every single Pokemon has somebody out there who loves them.
Like every Pokemon is someone's favorite out there.
Yeah, I actually...
I think there was like someone trying to do that.
They were like, I have this Excel sheet and like I'm going
through comments and say who your favorite Pokemon is.
And I will mark it down to see like if every Pokemon out
there has a...
has someone that loves them it's like when you go to the
Pokemon store in Japan and there's like a random Pokemon
that's a plushie and it's like a nice merch for like a
random like what are you happy?
and you're just like somebody does love you who's what's a
random one um Dunspars Dunspars somebody does love a
Dunspars it's one of my favorites I'm so basic.
I love Gengar.
But I do...
Gengar's cool.
I love Gengar.
I love Chandelure.
I love...
I need ghosty, really.
Well, that makes sense.
You would definitely...
I mean, you have to be a ghost trainer.
You would have to be.
Yeah, of course.
I would like to imagine if I were in, like, a Pokemon world,
I would be, like, the Hex Maniac, but, like, a little more,
like, Lolita in...
No, that really you would be!
I am manifesting art of this right now.
I'm manifesting fan art of this.
There's a girl in like the new game and she's very cute.
And wait, she has like a chandelure.
Wait, does anybody know her name?
Yeah, I don't look her up.
Help!
She's...
Gwen?
Gwen.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, she's so cute.
She's so cute.
I think if I were alive, I would look like her.
Yes, I think you would.
Surely, surely when you were alive and kicking, you were
kicking in this fit right here.
Mm-hmm.
She's so stinky.
The.
fairy tale girl just random random like trainer that you can
come across in the wild in Pokemon that's me fairy tale girl
fairy tale girl Pokemon oh yes that is that is Phoebe yes
Phoebe that's you that is the boy she's so cute she's really
cute she's got a forehead on her You can do tic-tac-toe on
that forehead.
Oh yeah.
That's a good forehead.
I think if you pushed both of our bangs up, we would both
have really big foreheads too.
Which I think, honestly, I got no issue because that's more
surface area to give a little soft kisses.
Little forehead kisses.
You're so cute, Vipi, you're so right.
We can have our little foreheads covered.
No pieces.
Though we say that, but I feel like our communities might
just play tic-tac-toe on the foreheads instead.
Yeah, I think.
Probably.
They would like.
Yeah, it's okay.
I'll give you a little forehead kiss.
I'll give you forehead kisses.
Yeah, they would draw stupid stuff.
They would be like, I'm with stupid and like draw an arrow
down.
Arrow down.
Cruel and unusual punishment.
Your bangs move so much, I'm watching them.
I'm, like, mesmerized by them.
Oh, thank you.
I love how bouncy my hair is.
I love your little curls.
They make me so happy.
They also look like a yummy ice cream, and I kind of just
want...
I've been thinking about straightening my hair recently.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Like, straightening it more.
The curls, the waves are natural.
Yeah, usually, yeah.
It's just kind of like how the ectoplasm lays.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Man, some people would kill for those waves.
They're so nice.
I can't believe they're all natural.
What about yours?
I got some natural waves as well.
Except they wave in whatever way they want to.
And sometimes not in the way that I want them to.
Someone asked, can we play battleship on y'all's foreheads?
Probably.
Can you?
Yes.
Should you?
Is the question.
We'll just lie down.
It'll like... Actually, I feel like that would be kind of
relaxing to like...
You know, like when someone plays with your hair or
something?
Like, just having like someone on your...
Play with your forehead.
Look, how about this?
You can play battleship or whatever you want on my forehead
if you also give headpads at the same time.
So true.
equivalent experience oh that's been one of my dreams is to
like go to a head spa as well you haven't been i've never
been wait you've been yeah oh my gosh wait how is it is it
as amazing it's it's amazing everybody everybody here should
go to a head spa at least once in once in their afterlife
like for real it's so oh my gosh it's okay wait i have this
one place that i I have a place that I love in Japan.
I will take you.
Oh, I would love that.
I would love that.
I love that.
Yeah.
Because it's like, I don't know, I feel like you get a lot
of tension around your head when you're like, just like, you
get stressed out, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
And a lot of them will do kind of like a shoulder massage
too.
So you get, you get a lot of, oh man.
Oh, it's so nice.
It's so nice.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think with like ectoplasm, but it does, it gets
kind of nodded, like it gets all bunched up in spots.
You gotta massage the ectoplasm, make it nice and squimsy
again.
Yeah, it's like a dough, you know?
Yeah.
Mint is a cookie, confirm.
I'm a cookie!
It's gone, Kit Kat.
Happy birthday!
Would you say?
Oh, you're sweet!
Look at cookie!
No, I think you're sweet.
Different flavors of cookie.
If we were a cookie, what flavor would you be?
I mean, probably a honey cookie.
Though, to be honest, I haven't made like...
I have not made honey cookies myself before, so how would
that even...
I don't know.
I don't even...
I don't think I've ever tried one.
Yeah.
Mmm.
But I love honey.
Maybe something like I've um some people you can use flowers
like not just for decoration and like cooking and baking but
also you can like bake them into things and And they can
like add a little bit of an aroma to it and And yeah so
maybe something with some honey and flowers.
I need to try your baking I really want you to try well one
day I will bake for you.
I promise.
I'm excited
Probably, right?
I feel like that, like a, was a thin mint?
Yeah, like a thin mint!
Yeah, I'm very...
Now wait for Girl Scout season to come around.
Oh, yeah.
What's your favorite Girl Scout cookie?
Well, I do like thin mints, to be honest.
Especially with, like, a milk.
But...
Oh, yeah.
What was it?
The, um...
I was just told this recently, too.
Samoa's I really like A lot of people love Samoa I know a
lot of people who Samoa's are their favorite Yeah they're
pretty good What about you?
There were these like They were called Lemon Smiles or
something like this Yeah!
They had like the powdered sugar on them And they were so
good I haven't seen them in so long I wonder if they still
make up I do wonder I think they have some other lemon ones
that they make in different areas too that are like a little
like they're thin and they got like a little lemon like
frosting layer on the bottom too those were my favorite
Scout lemon cookies I were you guys too were you ever a Girl
Scout I was not do I seem like I would be I don't know maybe
I feel to me because I was a Girl Scout for so long I feel
like everybody you were a Girl Scout I was deep in Girl
Scout.
I feel like every girl is a Girl Scout because I was so
like...
I was in.
Every girl's got the Girl Scout potential in them.
Uh-huh.
Wait, there's so many new ones now that I'm looking at on
their website that looks so good.
Girl Scout cookies.
I think I'm just hungry and I definitely want cookies.
Same, same.
Oh, they got...
Whoa, Adventurfuls.
Yeah, that's what I was looking at.
Caramel flavored cream.
We're going to make everybody hungry.
Oh, I mean, this stream was going to devolve into food talk
at some point.
That's so true.
We got to get it out of our system because we can't eat the
cookie run cookies.
We got to eat regular cookies.
Oh, the peanut butter ones are good, too.
Yeah, I would be...
Oh, there was a smore one that was good.
The what one?
There was a smore one that was really good, too.
You know what?
I don't know.
Last time I bought Girl Scout cookies.
Maybe I'm a fake Girl Scout.
Oh, no.
It's like...
Nowadays, I feel like when we were like little kids in
school, there were lots of opportunities to buy Girl Scout
cookies because like our classmates would have them.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, toasties.
I also liked toasties.
Toasties.
What the heck?
What is that one?
Yeah.
Oh, that one that like had...
a snickerdoodle like a like a like a ginger cookie with like
a frosting on the bottom that sounds so good oh that sounds
good they just got rid of them like literally last month or
something what the heck why would they do that french toast
inspired cookies dipped in delicious icing oh why'd they get
rid of it why yeah what a cute name to a toastier toastier
would be outside of like grocery stores and I would go up to
people and be like, do you want to buy cookies?
How can like how many times would they like say yes out of
like five?
I don't know.
It's been so long now.
I have such a hard time saying no to girl stuff that are
trying to sell me cookies.
Me too because partially because of the cookies.
I know how difficult it was before when I did it.
So I'm like, yeah, I'll buy your cookies.
But the boxes are like $7 a box or something.
So it's like...
I know.
Inflation.
Recession indicator.
The price of Girl Scout cookies going on.
They're crazy expensive now, but they're still so delicious.
So I'll get like a box or two.
At least.
Yummy.
When is Girl Scout cookie season?
Oh, it feels like all the time now, but at the same time...
I know, right?
Let's see, Girl Scout Cookie Season.
It is...
Google says it, January through April.
Oh, so now!
Now!
Get your cookies!
That's your cookies!
Oh my gosh.
I am getting hungry.
I don't need to.
No.
I got a bag of nuts right here.
Oh yeah, handful of nuts, baby.
Handful of nuts.
That's me.
Handful of nuts, cookie.
Do it.
Oh, I hear the crunch.
You can hear it crunch?
Can you guess the nut?
Almond.
The nut expert right here.
Oh my gosh.
I could tell from the crunch.
Wow, wait, wow!
That's actually really impressive!
That's really impressive!
Now, when I think about it though, if it was like walnuts,
there would be barely any crust.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Or like a cashew even, like it would be pretty soft.
It's like kind of like an in-between.
You're right.
That crunch could only be an almond.
You're so big brain.
What?
It could have been a peanut, I guess too.
But it sounded like deeper than like a peanut crunch.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's like a heavier crunch.
Yeah, yeah, I sound like a heavier crunch.
I'm learning so much.
One day this knowledge will be useful.
I'll like...
I don't think so.
No, I think so.
I'll be held hostage.
And then they'll be like, you cannot escape this room until
you guess exactly what kind of nut the other hostage in the
room next to you is eating.
Listen through this payphone.
I put the payphone up to my ear.
Oh, my God.
And I hear a deep crunch.
And I'm like, and then I'll flash back to this moment.
To you being like, it's an almond.
Because it has a deeper crunch.
And then I'll be like, thank you, Mint.
A single tear will fall.
And I'll be like, sir, it's an almond.
And they'll be like, how?
How could you have known?
I guess we'll release both you and the other hostage.
I'm like imagining the kidnapper as like, as like jigsaw
voice and he's like do you want to hear a crunch and it's
like precisely exactly yeah i think i think honestly like
almonds cashews and walnuts would be pretty easy
wait maybe i just okay a lot of nuts Walnut is like a soft,
barely crunch.
Yeah, yeah.
And an almond is a heavy, big crunch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What about a cashew?
I don't eat cashews very often.
I know that they're like, they're like little guy shaped.
Yeah.
But like, it's like a little shrimp.
A little shrimp.
Yeah, shrimp.
I think it's like right in the middle of an almond and a
walnut.
And a walnut.
Oh.
So that's the, the, the nut softness meter.
The nut softness meter.
Walnut, cashew, almond.
Almond is definitely the crunchiest, I believe.
And peanuts.
Your peanuts fall on the nut softness meter.
They're awesome.
I don't know what it is, though.
There's just a bit about an almond that makes such a
specific sound.
But peanuts are also quite crunchy.
They just don't have as deep of a crunch.
They have like a lighter.
So there may be between...
Oh, what are those guys called?
Oh, cashews and almonds.
Yeah.
Maybe.
It's like, it's like still like a crunchy crunch, but it's
the pitch is higher.
Um, peanuts are legume.
We were at the same exact time.
I don't care.
Yeah, um, I don't care.
Nice.
I'm sorry, guys.
We're just hungry.
I have, like, dinner waiting for me.
I'll eat it after stream.
I'm excited.
What kind of dinner are you going to have?
I have, like, some stuffed bell peppers.
Oh, the peppers again.
What are they stuffed with?
Meat and cheese.
Oh, maybe that would make up for the fact that they're
stuffed inside peppers maybe i would eat yeah i am i gotta
go up i gotta i gotta eat my bell by my peppers you don't
eat i wonder what the nutritional what is like a nutritional
value of a bell pepper though like i know they probably are
like vitamin a or something i don't know vitamin something
yes vitamin p someone said the roasting takes out a lot of
the harshness of the peppers but green peppers are pretty
bitter but red peppers and yellow peppers aren't maybe I
should try.
I should start easy mode with the the yellow and red ones
and then I'll go up to green ones and then I'll go up to
jalapenos.
Oh wait.
And then I'll go up to ghost peppers.
Wait, wait, wait.
I am going to grab a snack though because we are talking
about I have some.
Yeah, please do.
I have some crackers here.
Ooh!
Yay!
Some cheese for those crackers.
I did earlier.
I did.
Can you hear him?
I can.
Sorry.
I did at the start.
It's okay.
Hold on.
Yummy.
Sorry we're talking about food so much, you guys.
You guys can crunch with us.
It's the crunching stream.
Crunchy stream.
Yeah, you'll have to work up to a ghost pepper one day.
Can you handle spicy food well?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Give me any spice.
I can tank it.
Wow.
Yeah, don't reach out.
I believe you, Mint.
I believe you.
There's no way you would lie to me.
Yeah, of course, of course, of course.
No, no, no.
We're closer than that.
Exactly.
I have no reason to lie to you, honestly.
Yeah, no reason, no reason at all.
Not to impress you or anything.
No, of course.
That's why I'm going to be bringing...
Extra spicy curry, just the way you like it.
Next time I see you.
You can handle spice?
Probably not as well as you.
You're like the spice expert.
You're super spicy.
That's literally what they call me.
Super spicy.
Yeah.
Mint spicy phantom.
That's your full name.
You know, though, I can only have a curry on a full moon.
So, I might not even...
On a full moon?
Yeah, depending on the time of the day, year, the seasons, I
don't know if I'll be able to have it.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
That's so sad.
Well, then I'll just make sure to visit you on the next full
moon.
It's also...
I forgot to...
Also, and also Jupiter and Venus need to be aligned.
Can you be aligned?
Oh, shoot.
It's so specific.
get to have curry ever oh that sucks so bad on a leap year
well on a leap year that's crazy when is the next leap year
i'm wait i'm actually curious about this when is next leap
year
2028 oh in two years i can have curry again maybe if i can
have curry again well here's the thing then then i can just
get my two year long curry brewing now?
Every day I'll add one more pepper to it.
And then it'll be just the way you like it by the time that
Jupiter and Venus are aligned and there's a full moon on a
leap year.
It has healing properties.
Did I mention that Oprah Winfrey needs to be there?
Damn, I'm gonna call her up right now!
We have plans in two years, Oprah!
It's okay.
mint it's all right you know what we can have we can have
lots and lots of mint ice cream there as well because well
there was there was one time when uh um i used to work at
this like after school program and the bosses the super
duper strict bosses were away on a vacation for like a week
leaving me and the other like college-aged kids in the
office by ourselves.
And what the guys in the office did was bring in like super
duper spicy hot sauce.
Like the challenge kind.
Oh my god.
And the...
For the sake of not dying, the fridge in the office was
filled with milk and such.
Okay.
This sounds just like the kind of thing that a bunch of
college kids left alone.
onto their own devices while the parents are gone would do
it really dies the the first guy that tried it he like ran
to the bathroom crying so sad i was like you left your milk
you let the milk it's it's here why did he go to the
bathroom i don't know there's no milk in there why would he
go to the bathroom there's no milk no what a dummy i'm not
gonna think about it too much i know
No, I don't think so either.
Wait, what's the spiciest thing you can handle then?
Mm-hmm.
Well, there was a time recently when a friend of mine made,
like, Korean army stew, which is, like, just take a bunch
of, like, a Shin rambun and stuff, and then put, like, just,
like, throw a bunch of stuff in there, like, a mushroom,
anoki mushrooms, and sausages, and a bunch of yummy stuff.
But then this friend put like all the spice packets for all
the Shin Ramiyons because it was like a big pot of it So
several packets of Shin Ramiyon were used, but then you
probably shouldn't use All of the spice packets too And that
was like My nose was running Oh I was crying a little bit
But it was delicious I could eat it Can I tank it?
Will it hurt?
Well your stomach regret it probably probably but it was
tasty it was so yummy i i do avoid spice when i can though
you're stronger than i am i think i would be sent beyond the
afterlife i think i just might reincarnate it would just you
think oh no i i would get sent past heaven i do not collect
$200.
Do not stop and go.
Like, I just just straight into a new body.
No!
We don't want that.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna cancel that two years from now curry party.
Let's just do ice cream instead.
Let's do ice cream instead.
Yeah.
I'll bake you some cookies.
What if I become lactose intolerant in two years?
so i was just talking to someone about this the other day oh
no you can like you can like exposure therapy yourself into
getting rid of your lactose intolerance and i know because i
did it to myself it's a mindset it's a mindset lactose
intolerance is a skill issue
just take it Yeah, so like, I wasn't lactose intolerant for
most of my life.
But I loved, so I loved cheese.
And then at some point, when I, when I got into college, I
like suddenly was lactose intolerant for some reason.
But I tanked it until I no longer was lactose intolerant
anymore.
And it only took a couple of years.
So, yeah.
Be the change you want to see in the world.
Exactly.
do it.
I believe in you.
You can be whatever you want it to be and your gut biome can
be whatever you want it to be.
A couple years.
Wait, so what is the method that you do?
What is, what do you do?
You ignore it.
You eat whatever the heck you want.
Probably like have a lot.
Have like dairy on a regular basis.
You ignore the bathroom or you just oh no you you just you
tank the bathroom you tank it and then eventually it won't
happen anymore you know in a couple years everybody in a
couple of years well you're not lactose intolerant though
right now are you i don't think so oh good let's let's hope
it stays that way how would you know maybe if i i'll test it
i'll eat a bunch of cheese and then see yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Yeah!
Wait, yeah, I've had so much mac and cheese.
I think I'm good.
I think I'm not.
Yeah, you're probably good.
I believe in you.
If you don't eat dairy for a long time, though, do you think
you'd become lactose intolerant?
I feel like you might.
I feel like...
I feel like if you don't eat like anything for a long period
of time, then your body may become less tolerant of it,
possibly.
Oh, that's how it works.
Oh my gosh.
I'll lose the tolerance.
I gotta keep eating cheese.
Yeah.
That's you.
I gotta keep it up.
You're doing a great job.
You've been doing the great job so far.
Says you're definitely certified nutritionist, Phoebe.
Uh-huh.
Keep it up, Minto.
A cheese a day keeps the lactose intolerance away.
Yeah.
Keep cheeses.
Keep cheesing.
I'm always cheesing.
Favorite, do you have a favorite cheese?
You know, I'm a basic, I'm a basic ghost and I just like
cheddar.
Like a super sharp cheddar though.
Well, no.
I mean, that's not, that's not that basic.
Like, is it because like there are different kinds of
cheddars, like you said.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah, I love a sharp cheddar.
An umbrella term, a sharp one.
mouth oh yeah oh god there is there's like i love waffles
but sometimes they just like cut the roof of your mouth when
they're like when they're too toasty i think i'm thinking in
particular ego waffles probably i feel like ego waffles are
so soft what i don't know what it is maybe it's like belgian
well something there was something that i would put in my
mouth that would like cut the roof of it.
I don't remember what it was.
It might have been baguettes.
Like a hard, not pastry, a hard, like, oh, Captain Crunch.
There you go.
Captain Crunch.
Where did you get waffles for Captain Crunch?
I don't know.
They look a little similar.
Not Captain.
Not that guy.
I mean, that's the crunch, man.
It's got to crunch.
It's got to be it's got to be spiky.
It's a crunch.
Yeah, that's the real, that's how you know, that's how you
know, it's the legitimate Captain Crunch, not any imposter.
Exactly, exactly.
Phoebe, are you ready to cookie it up?
Oh yeah, I'm raring and ready to run to the Cookie Kingdom,
let's go.
Are we ready to cookie run, everybody?
Cookie dash, cookie jump, cookie run.
Cookie jump, yeah.
It could be cookie time.
I smell something.
something something just finished baking oh hi cookie run
kingdom what could it mean yeah you're telling me a cookie
runs this kingdom cookie does win this kingdom actually oh
yeah oh yeah we cookie running baby all right i want to play
actually the fifth anniversary opening because it's like so
epic um wait oh i just realized i don't have it streamed to
you feby i'm so sorry but it's the one we watched earlier
when that's okay i think i can just press play on it
probably i think i have it as well i think so so i would
like to play it because it's so epic and so cool and it's
not so that i can get my setup uh change no problem and
watch you guys cookie run kingdom is serious business watch
this serious serious okay this this opening is like so so
fun so do do do do do please watch oh wait wait sorry I just
realized I have the music going still oh no the game just
went into maintenance what wait no way wait oh oh
Look at, look at, look at the key.
There's no way.
Maybe we, maybe we stall a little bit more.
Maybe we, yeah, up a little bit more.
Wait, what time is that?
Oh my god.
Yeah, what time is it?
Like, oh my god.
Well, we can still talk about some stuff.
Oh my gosh, do you guys hear that music though?
Isn't it so ominous?
it's like i was like so shocked i was like maybe cookie run
is kind of scary oh shoot um well we're still gonna have you
guys um listen right quick wait let me actually oh gosh how
do i do this real quick um i could just yap
that's so funny it does say that it might take like an hour
um so let's give me one second everybody i'm so sorry um no
problem i'm gonna do this boy oh wait it already is like
that okay hold on You know what?
I'm just gonna close the game so that we can watch the
video.
Okay, one second.
And you guys can watch!
Darkness shall devour you.
Cookie run kingdom.
wow this would be where my cookie run kingdom was if i had
it
it's kind of insane i was like wow this is so intense it's
so crazy like so cookie run kingdom is one of the best
written games i have ever played
and stuff even the side events are so they've been I've
cried I have cried to cookie run kingdom before oh my gosh I
have um it can be very wholesome and heartwarming but also
like when it comes down to it the game is about as
existentialism and it's kind of yeah as cookie as extension
it is that serious it is I mean yeah we love like it's funny
how like so many like gotcha games or mobile games will like
actually have such amazing stories and you're just like but
i this is the game where i roll for for cute character for
my wife right yeah but um we can still talk about like you
know about cookie run kingdom in the meantime um we did run
this time in advance so i'm kind of like yeah Um, but for
those who don't know, um, that about Cookie Run Kingdom,
this, I wish you guys could see the, uh, what's it called?
Like the gate here?
Abandon all hope ye who enter here.
Like, it's so, why is it so epic and, like, spooky?
I know, right?
It has no right to be as good as it is.
Yeah, it sounds like, whoa, this ambiance is awesome.
Um, but yeah, Kingdom, uh, not Kingdom, Cookie Run Kingdom
is it?
It's a RPG city building mobile game and it's set in the
world of EarthBread where Cookie Heroes are set off on an
epic adventure to stop the forces of evil which seems to be
this entire arc right now with the fifth anniversary.
Yeah, they're celebrating their fifth anniversary which was
released on January 13th.
I can't believe, I feel like I've heard about Cookie Run
Kingdom forever now like five years i'm like i thought this
game is like so much older no offense but they had like we
had oven break which was the actual like the cookie run
where you like where they run and stuff yeah yeah yeah um
but then cookie run kingdom i i personally and that was
that's been going since like 2016 um so you probably have
her wow happy oh my gosh happy almost 10 years cookie run in
that that is that's this year like 20.
oh no wait a second oven break actually came out in 2009.
no oh my god wait what what huh
the original oven break oh it wasn't called cookie run at
that time it was called uh it was just oven break and it was
2009 that's that means it's almost i'm not going to think
about this 20 years old well i well i didn't know about the
whole thing but for quick cookie run kingdom it's the fifth
anniversary which is like i mean so many people now know
about cookie run kingdom itself so yeah um i wish i could
show you guys the the update which has we have this new
chapter episode 13 which is called on the border of light
and darkness yes yeah it's the ultimate battle between good
and evil and yeah it's they're saying that kind of the best
time to start playing yeah yeah i mean for veterans and new
players alike i think everybody could get really into the
story so yeah for me personally cookie run kingdom was my
very first cookie run got into it during pandemic and it was
like it made me so happy like you get so attached to them
and I think I hope they have a super happy five-year
anniversary because they've they put they put a lot of love
the developers put so much love into all the characters and
the game and you can tell they do like these directs that
are kind of like you know like any other game directs and
stuff like that wait those are always so fun yeah they're
fun they're so fun and they had one back in December to like
wrap up the end of the the end of the year and look at look
forward to like new new things that they're developing and
um and it's it's been it's really really cute it's really
cute one of my favorite things about cookie run kingdom just
from a visual um perspective since you know i haven't played
so much of it but it's just how detailed the like designs
can get like you wouldn't think that like a cookie could
have like i know could have such like an intricate and like
all of them look so like unique and fun like it's just It's
really, it's really awesome, I think.
Exactly.
There's, like we said earlier, like with Pokemon, there's a
cookie for everyone.
There is a cookie for everyone.
Yeah, there's over a hundred cookies, you guys.
There's over a hundred cookies.
Mm-hmm.
We do have some, you know, some coupons that we can, some
like coupon codes that we can give to you guys.
If you did want to, I think they're either already playing
Cookie Run Kingdom or if you, want to get into cookie run
kingdom this could probably really boost your uh your your
let's see so i'm gonna just start i'm just gonna start
posting them in the chat i'm gonna be like hey guys you
gotta heck yeah baby what's your favorite cookie iron really
good codes yeah let's see we have code cookie run kingdom
twilight live which will give you 15 fateful cookie cutters
5 000 4,500 rainbow cubes and 200 radiant biscuit dough and
three butter amber so getting you look at that cookie run
crk twilight live what else we got here we're just gonna
here's the here's the website where you would redeem the
codes oh yes thank you thank you Phoebe yeah so redeem them
on this website you can get use code kingdom star 2026 to
get 555 EXP star jellies.
Should we put these on the screen?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's a good idea.
Let's just hear.
You know what they even sent me?
They sent me the cookie run font.
What?
Yeah!
Cookie run font?
No way!
Cookie run codes.
Let's see.
Hold on.
What was it?
It was like...
Cookie run font, baby.
Baby, it's so cute.
Their visual design is just so good.
Wait, did it change?
Maybe it didn't.
Run.
Codes.
Wait, one second.
Guys, these codes are really like...
They give you some really good rewards.
I redeemed them not too long ago.
OBS is rejecting me from being able to use the font.
That's okay, though.
It's okay.
We carry on.
Where are my codes?
So we have, like I said, this one.
Boom.
We have Kingdom Star 2026 for your 555 EXP.
And then also all of these.
I'm just going to throw them at you.
Bam!
So many.
Wow.
So many!
They're so generous.
We'll do it in like a cool, dark, red outline.
Cookie Run Codes.
For you, everybody.
To enjoy.
For you.
And you.
What is your favorite cookie then, Phoebe?
And why do you like your cookie?
Out of the cookie run cookies?
Yes.
Okay.
I would say...
Possibly Milky Way.
cookie well actually no no no no i will say my favorite in
terms of cuteness milky way cookie is super duper cute she's
a little train conductor and she's always sleepy she just
wants to sleep which is kind of bad i guess if you're in
charge of a train but like uh well trains are they could be
they could just go themselves right like technology nowadays
yeah i do also um oh yeah I'm sorry, keep going if you still
have more.
Oh, she's really cute and she's a charged cookie, so she
just charges at you with her little train.
And I love her so much.
And she goes boo-boo or something like that.
I use the Japanese voice pack, but she makes really cute
noises.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Aw.
But I think, I think maybe in terms of like story and stuff,
Cotton Cookie's one of my favorites.
She's voiced by Jorge Ayui in the Japanese version, helps
yeah baby oh my gosh wait so this game has like a stacked
say you line up in japanese english japanese probably also
korean and chinese the the the voice actor lineup is stacked
let's go it is so stacked it really is i've saw there's so
many cookies i guess it would like oh my gosh wait what if
phoebe cookie one day that's one that's one of my dreams is
to i I love Cookie Run Kingdom so much.
I'm like, like, sing for you guys or voice act for you guys.
I would love to be a Cookie Run Kingdom.
Hoorayayui.
You can change the voice language.
You can actually, like on this screen that we're on right
now, you can change it.
So, but one thing we can go over is with the fifth
anniversary, they do have like some new gotcha characters
that I want to show off a little bit to you guys.
So the first one I want to show is the mold dough cookie.
Which like...
Wow!
Look at...
Whoa!
Wow!
I didn't think like...
See, they're like...
A moldy cookie.
It would be so cool looking.
I know, right?
It's so cool!
So cool!
What is it?
I wonder what the, like the little symbols say.
I wonder.
I know, right?
What kind of language is this in?
Cookie language.
But he's pretty cool.
And then we also have my personal favorite, which is the
Dark Enchantress cookie.
Hello.
Hi.
Hello, Dark Enchantress.
So this, like, this, this new Dark Enchantress cookie.
Yeah.
It's like, because we've seen her before.
But, like, she's never looked this...
Evil?
Cool?
Awesome?
And, and cool, cool.
Like, like, like, I don't know, she was like an old lady
looking cookie before.
Like, with the, like, Maleficent vibes.
Right, right, right.
But she's kind of like...
She's kind of bad like this.
Yeah!
This is definitely a look, like, the cool look.
Mmm, very cool.
And she's got, she is the...
The bad guy.
The prime bad guy in the whole Cookie Run Kingdom story.
So imagine her on your team.
Like this cookie.
You know.
Like this cookie's magic.
All the evilness and everything on your team.
You can have an evil team.
You really could.
I mean all that power, baby.
But not only that.
There are also two costumes.
And I love costumes.
They're very fun.
Uh, one second.
Bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo, wait,
where'd they go?
Oh, here we go.
The costumes in this game were so peak.
I know.
Oh my gosh, I'm obsessed with the Eternal Sugar one.
So we have Eternal Sugar and Shadow Milk.
Da-da-da-da.
They're both.
And so, like, the thing with costumes in Cookie Run are that
they're, like, they're, uh...
Uh...
What, what, what?
I'm having a brain fart about it right now.
But, like, Alt Worlds?
all like what is it called but it's like an AU it's an a
they're like AU that's fine yeah so this one's got like got
a story and I think like in this one shadow milk is the
puppet and she's like the she's the the puppeteer the I oh
yes I was seeing that there's like a video of like shadow
milk and like how yeah actually let me grab some of the
videos like we can just show yeah I'm but we can show you
guys these kind of like they gave me so many things thank
goodness but um the let me see i gotta find it real quick um
oh i have a link if you want to use a youtube link i think i
oh wait i do have hold on let me see the video video yeah
yeah yeah let me just download it really quick but very very
cool get cool trailers too i love the sugar one it's so cute
so so so let's see and then let me grab some okay the
costume music video or MV PV sorry promotional video it
might be a little loud so give me one second everybody to
stop one second please one second sorry everybody no problem
no problem I'm so excited I'm on the edge of my seat yeah
You guys are going to get to see the cool animation.
They always have super cool animations for Cookie Run
Kingdom as well.
Like, I'm going to...
Why does it look so good?
Just make a TV series already.
Make an anime.
Okay, I'm going to quit the game real quick so we can hear
it without the...
Without the BGM.
And...
Play!
True masters never follow the script.
I was like watching this earlier.
I was like, oh, what a diva.
puppet part came in, I was like, oh, sorry, I'm like talking
over it.
But I was okay.
When I'm on tape, there's no one else.
But you!
Such a demon.
I know.
Oh, the foolish king.
He always is.
Trapped in a tragedy of his own making.
Our show will go on forever and ever.
So cute!
Legendary costumes!
But me!
Shadow Milk is very, very, very good.
They're both, I think they're both in the meta right now
too.
These two are Strunk.
Strunk.
Let me pull up our ambience again.
And they're just good characters.
maybe the game will be kind to us and go out of maintenance
early oh please that would be nice that would be very kind
it is sick though right like oh my gosh you wouldn't expect
it it's so awesome oh cookie i saw some people in chat
earlier we're like is this game really just about cookie
it's about cookies but it's about more than the cookies it's
about it's about humanity self and it's about cool costumes
and fake effects and and boy bands there was a sorry this is
totally off topic yeah but like there was a uh boy band that
came out of one of the events in cookie run kingdom i have
he had merch for them i have a i have a hoodie with them on
it here oh my god
They sang.
They had a song and everything.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's so cute.
And there was a rhythm game.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
What the heck?
That's so awesome.
What's your...
Like, did they have, like, a bunch of songs or just one?
They had the one.
I wish they came out with more.
Ah.
Um.
But it was really cute.
And one of the characters in Japanese is voiced by, uh, by,
uh, Kamiyan.
Ah!
You know, she kind of...
Yeah, and I was like, okay, he's my he's my Yoshi, or he's
my bias and bad for his licorice cookie.
That's so funny.
They just do stuff.
They had one year for April Fool's, they had a they had a
dating sim.
Like a visual novel dating sim inside the game as well.
And they were like animal, Bishonen and Bishojo versions of
several of the cookies.
and that's just Cookie Run is so much more than just what
you think it is it is really good it sounds so good I love
when they do when like Siri is kind of like when like
there's like spin-off things and like they like kind of they
put more like they produce them and everything so it's like
exactly exactly I think I think You'll love it so much,
Mint, if you play more of it as well.
Yeah!
Oh, hold on.
One second, I'm getting some things message to me.
Oh yeah, no problem, no problem.
How about you guys, chat?
Those of you guys that play Cookie Run or Cookie Run Kingdom
or any Cookie Run game, do you have favorite cookies?
Why?
Why your favorite?
Never played it.
What kind of cookie would you want if you never played?
Mmm.
Yeah, what kind of cookie would you want?
What kind of flavor?
Pumpkin pie cookie.
He's cute.
She's very cute.
She's spooky.
She's kind of mint core a little bit.
Really?
Yeah, she's like the Halloween cookie.
And she's got a...
She's a little bit...
She's like cute.
So cute.
But also, she's got a creepy air about her.
Because she's got like a doll.
And the doll like transforms for her.
attack and stuff.
White Lily Cookie, White Lily Cookie is very, very good.
Very, very good.
She's also one of the main characters.
Yay.
Your friend is obsessed with Shadow Milk Cookie.
Shadow Milk Cookie.
Yeah, he is kind of baby girl.
Alpagato Cookie.
Yeah, Alpagato's good.
Salted Caramel.
Oh, Snapdragon.
Baby.
Yeah, they got the little baby cookies that are like their
like rarity is like not epic or like super epic or anything
it's like friend or something i don't remember friends
that's so sweet why and they're just little guys there's
like um yeti cookie is one of them and then snapdragon
cookie is one of them there's like a little baby uh hold on
where are they the special ones special cookies i am being
told guys i'm really really sorry that the uh update
happened right as we were going it to play the game so i'm
really sorry i think what i'm being told to do is um come
back in about one hour i will make another waiting room and
raid into it i'm so so sorry you guys but um it do be like
that the the scuff we we we vibe we go wait Phoebe you have
a stream though oh no I will push my stream are you sure yes
what time are you scheduling this for and then I will change
my stream I'm so sorry don't be sorry I love I love you and
I love Cookie Run Kingdom and and I will I will I will be
there for you thank you what time you want to do Um, it
would be, I think, 6.30 your time.
Okay, so that's in, like, oh, like an hour, so that's when
it's supposed to start.
Yeah, and then I think, uh, it would be...
And at 7.30.
Hold on.
Okay, okay, hold on.
This is what they're telling me here.
I'm just gonna send you a screenshot of everything that's
being sent to me at the very moment.
so that you are there we go okay thank you so let me set up
the next waiting room guys and then we will raid into it and
i hope that you will come back in about an hour i'm really
sorry don't be sorry at all we cannot have anticipated this
yeah everyone give lots of love to minfo for doing her best
thank you don't worry i'll be i'll be here with you thank
you let me just copy everything back over again and there we
go and um part two yes so see you guys for part two see you
guys for part two thank you see you in a bit i will read
into it real short